welcome to the presentation on level 4
subtraction let's get started with some
problems
so the first problem i have here is
minus
399.
so just like we did with i believe that
we also did borrowing in the level 3
subtraction we have to go through all
the digits in the top number starting
with the top right digit
and make sure that they are larger than
the digit below it because you can only
subtract
a
a a smaller number from a larger number
you can't do it the other way until at
least until we learn negative numbers so
let's go through this and check make
sure all the top numbers are larger well
immediately we see no well this 0 is not
larger than 9 so we have to borrow to
make the 0 bigger so we do is we borrow
uh one well some people say we're
borrowing a one some people will say i
mean borrowing a one from the tens place
is really like borrowing a ten
so
for for simplicity let's just say we're
borrowing a one so you borrow one from
this 2 and this 10
this 10 will become a
0 sorry will become a 10
and since we borrow that 1 this 2 will
become a 1.
right we took 1 away from this 2 and we
gave it to the 0 to make 10.
we actually took 10 away from this 2
because this 2 is in the tens place i
don't want to confuse you too much just
if just the mechanics of it are we took
1 away from the 2 and we put it in front
of the 0 to make 10.
now let's keep checking so now we have a
1 in this place
1 is smaller than 9 so we have to borrow
again
so we borrow
1 from this 2 now
so this 2 now becomes 1
and this one will now become an 11.
so now we have a 10 is larger than a 9.
11 is larger than a 9
1 is not larger than 3 so we have to
borrow again this this is a good problem
it's uh
maybe i should have warmed all up a
little bit more but it involves a lot of
borrowing so in order to bar we do the
same thing over again this one
will become an 11
and it's gonna borrow from this three
which will become a two
i think we're done now 10 is larger than
9 11 is larger than 9 11 is larger than
3 2 is larger than nothing 3 is larger
than nothing
so now we're ready to subtract this is
the easy part 10 minus 9 is 1
eleven minus nine
is two
eleven
minus three
is
eight
two minus nothing is two
and three minus nothing is three
so we get thirty two thousand eight
hundred and twenty one so the important
thing to the the only thing that makes
this harder than just normal subtraction
is that you have to know how to do the
borrowing and the way i do the borrowing
might be different than the way you
learn in school but i think it's easier
because you do all of the borrowing at
once instead of switching back and forth
between borrowing and subtracting so all
we did here we said the zero is less
than nine let's borrow one the zero
becomes a ten because we got this one
right here
we got this one from this 2 and this 2
became a 1. i think you might see
the pattern if we do a couple more
problems so let's do a couple more
if i
had see
twenty five thousand
six hundred and thirty
three
minus
five hundred
and 78
it's the same drill
we start at the top right and we make
sure that the digits on top are larger
than the digit below it immediately we
see 3 is smaller than 8 so we have to
borrow
so this 3 will become 13
and we borrow from this 3 which will now
become 2.
right we took a 1 away from this 3
became 2 and this 1 is right here
13 is not larger than 8 but 2 is now a
lot smaller than 7 so we have to bar
again this 2
becomes a 12
and the 6
will become a 5.
13 is larger than 8 12 is larger than 7.
is the same as 5 so you can actually do
the subtraction if
because 5 minus 5 is 0 if
as long as the top number is not smaller
than the number below it and then
obviously this 5 is larger than this is
0 and this 2 is larger than this nothing
here
so now we're ready to subtract 13 minus
is 5
12 minus seven
is five
five minus five is zero
five minus nothing is five
and we have to bring down the two so the
answer is twenty five thousand
twenty thousand twenty five thousand and
fifty five
so let's do a problem now that i think
will will confuse you a little bit more
because the borrowing isn't as easy you
have to actually borrow from a couple
places
let's say i had
thirty
seven thousand
zero zero and two
minus
let's say i had
one hundred and fifty-five
so it's the same drill
so this 2 is less than 5 so you have to
borrow so this 2
will become a 12.
but huh there's a 0 here so you can't
borrow from the zero some people will
let you bar from the zero but i think
that just confuses things because you
can't borrow from a zero there's nothing
there so instead of borrowing from the
zero we look to this zero well there's
still nothing there so now we look oh
there's a seven here
so what we do is instead of borrowing a
one from the zero which is hard to do
we borrow one from the 700 from this
whole 700
and what is 700 minus 1
right it's 699.
so that 700 becomes 699.
we could cross all of this out and now
let's check our numbers again 12 is
larger than 5
nine is larger than five
nine is larger than one six is larger
than nothing and three is larger than
nothing so we're ready to subtract
12 minus five is seven
nine minus five is four
nine minus one is eight
six minus nothing is six
three minus nothing is three so there
we're done the answer is thirty six
thousand eight hundred and forty seven i
think we could have time for one more
problem
let's say i had
minus let's say it's five hundred
and two
same drill
one is less than two so we have to
borrow
turn that into 11. but you can't borrow
from a zero so you're gonna have to
borrow from this entire 20.
well what's 20 minus 1 right
it's 19. so this becomes a 19.
so let's check again 11 is greater than
2 check 9 is greater than 0 check
uh oh 1 is not greater than 5 so we have
to borrow again
this 1 becomes an 11
and we barred from this 3 which becomes
a 2.
11 is greater than two
nine is greater than zero
eleven is greater than five two is
obviously greater than nothing below it
it's ready to subtract
eleven minus two
is nine
nine minus zero
is nine eleven minus five
is six
and two minus nothing is two
so three thousand two hundred and one
minus five hundred and two is equal to
two thousand six hundred and nine i
think you're now ready to try some of
the level 4 subtraction problems you
just always have to remember
do your borrowing first make sure all
the numbers on top are are larger than
all that or at least as large as all the
numbers on the bottom and then you can
just do your subtraction like a normal
subtraction problem
i hope you have some fun doing this
talk to you later